Cut in somewhere there after i.
You got to go in and do this
in the trends weekly egg.
I mean if i can be right.
The relationship between freedom.
And community is of course so
intense that most likely it needs to
talk about other factors as well.
In order to get more of a circular
view instead of polarization.
You can look at the niman experience
as being one where people came with an
ideal of being very community or sharing
everything and have gone full circle
and become fairly.
Suburban
and separate families
but also within the first three
months. Of tangible fours.
Those separate houses being started.
After much discussion and much talk.
There was simply the need on dave getters
and mandy give us a start to have
a separate space because they had
children the force of children
drove them to start work on the
first independent new
house. A ton of will force.
And just to not be so. In trouble.
I'm not just for themselves
but for other people because children
really really want to huge amount of their.
Space their privacy and their
ownership of their parents that
when those parents come through the door.
They're there with those children
and very quickly it became.
Well as soon as that started within days.
I came to the conclusion of bringing
in the word homeless and of
and saying look there's going this is
going to happen all over the place.
But let's try to have those houses
being built in clusters of houses.
Let's call them hamlets and let's
try to get those to work together.
In a particular area and to share
some of their land together
and maybe their fruit crops or certainly
their access and whatever things
that they want to share together.
Let's just encourage people to share.
I suppose their block.
If you are thinking in terms of the city
you'd most likely be looking at all the
backyards in one particular block
or you might be looking at the in
some streets of the front yards
and in a street because the street is
in fact more part of the place than the
backyards and anyway.
That started and we we
had these hamlets going.
Right away. There was
that level of privacy.
You know right away at the beginning
there was always a privacy in people's
economics. There was no. Sharing of.
Of money in a wider sense. And.
It's just as likely that in the future
neiman will become more commune
or in terms of the work that
people are doing together.
Because when people are
building their own houses
and they're sharing a bit
of labor with each other
but they're basically they're building
their own houses in that phase
that they're very isolated and
that's commune or in many ways.
So i think that over over time. Nim and.
Might become more sharing.
And hopefully with
that it might in fact be more willing
to worry about its common problems.
Its community problems and to share
responsibility for those community problems
and to actually step in
and take action about those.
I suppose for me as a writer in
nimbin there's a lot of individuals.
It's a lot of people who
don't fit into easy molds
and there's a lot of people who while.
Often falling into very
normal suburban patterns.
Also break a huge number
of those patterns.
So
that there's a bit more stirring
of my imagination into what
is possible and there's an
easier sharing of ideas
and i think some people like it here at
the bush the elder there's not many towns
where there is a theatre which is
just showing movies where the guests.
Actually come and talk to each other
for some half an hour beforehand
and at interval
and the interval is specially designed to
be ultra long extended interval in the
middle of a movie so that everyone
talks to whoever is there
that their friends of other
people they just meeting and
that the whole movie experience
is in fact as much a talking.
Commune all meeting place
experience as anything else.
It's almost like a church experience.
So that's really beautiful
and the bush the ed and the.
Just running here is something that's
really special for me. Also i love this.
But i love the factory as a building.
I think it's quite grand it's
got beautiful architectural.
Features and shape.
The whole valleys a very beautiful valley.
I've got a very close relationship
with the local curry population
and i work with them.
And i think that the whole valley
still has a huge potential which it.
It's just wanders on disregarding and.
Perhaps there in the future that potential
might actually be able to be utilized
and really unleashed an in-between
time i think i suppose it gives me the
chance to think about what.
Individual communities across the
world could be doing themselves at a
local neighborhood community level you
know i mean in the in the small thousands
maybe four to 16000. And in that field.
How much what can a can and community
of that size really do for itself
and how good a quality of life. Can it
have and what are the economics of that.
What is the reality of
that and what structures
and ideas have to actually
be consciously working for
that happen.
Yeah yeah that's.
Well i could just mention that part
of that sort of thinking of the.
Four to 16000 people is part
of what i've called a geo
village concept.
And it's related to ideas that i have
a conceptual framework that i have.
Which i go into an explore the question
of how many people do you need
working in what sort of ways
to have a post mechanical.
Community's economics
giving that quality of life
that. Includes the world.
That keeps people in contact with
and understanding the
latest ideas in the world
and able to actually put some of them into
place to actually utilize them into work
them through what's what
is the relationship.
We've we we've got some strong ideas now.
What a nomadic community
social economics pattern is
and we've got lots of examples
of agrarian such patterns
and we've got lots of
examples of mechanical wage.
Patterns but what
that post mechanical pattern
is no one quite knows.
Where.
For you.
Jumping from one idea to another
from one project to another the the
linking the linking things for
myself is is understanding reality
is is a clarifying is a is an exploring of
and testing out of
and then trying to be very specific
about what reality is how it works
and how it can work better. And.
All of these different stories musical
theater. Land.
And all of these different things
sort of just fit in with a pattern
that i explore in my brain trying
to cope with this mad reality
that we're stuck in and trying to simplify
and clarify it more than simplify i think.
The complexities ok as long
as we clear it and clarify
and make it easier to understand
it doesn't need to be simple.
We don't need to simplify
things to the extreme.
We can cope with a pretty complex world
as long as we're clear about the
complexities.
Ok.
Monday.
As you know. I'm daisy stewart.
I mean the bar in town. Dear.
The aquarius festival in 1973 place.
Before or after
or before very quiet nice peaceful town.
Before the festival.
Just say before before the
festival towers very quiet.
Peaceful and lovely place
to live. How was it.
Going down hill. I believe.
My business wasn't really.
Paying well at that time. And the extra
people that came certainly boosted it.
So what are your first reasons.
The first time.
I heard of it were three or
four guys and graeme dust
and wheels one of them arrived into town.
Enter the shop one day and started
to say what they proposed to do
that was the first i'd heard of
it. I sort of thought oh yeah.
This sounds alright.
You know i sort of didn't really
know what they were getting at.
At that time. So.
I think the biggest majority
were for having this festival.
There were two or three that weren't
but they didn't voice their
opinions if they were against it.
If you did but not not a reliable.
Much.
Not a real lot now i don't. I was
there briefly but i didn't stay.
To the whole of the meeting.
But i think the biggest percentage of
the business people in the town were.
Sort of on along the line just
thinking oh yes this could be good.
So why did you think.
Well financially. Of course.
Financially i thought you know would.
Help us all so what was his
first name.
There was a lot of
activity leading up to it.
But not a great big.
Lot of people arrive
but there were a few running around
working on getting this together getting
that the get a i think the first day
or so i don't think any of us realised
that the nimbin would ever have as
many people in it you know coming in.
Buses and what have you.
And of course everybody was interested
interested to see what they look like and.
Money that. First person.
I was probably a little bit shocked
that the way they dressed and.
You know the state of their
hair and you know shoes and all
that sort of thing you
know it was probably
but we could say i was shocked.
After that.
Well i made a lot of really nice people
and i got to like a lot of people.
Made some good friends among
them. And. I sort of.
There weren't as far as i'm
concerned and in my business.
There wasn't a real lot of people who i
disliked there were a few but not many.
I am i really did sort of get
on well with all of them
and i think they go well with me too. So.
It's gone.
Well i don't have many memories all i did
was work i didn't get out into the field
or out side my shop actually where we
work from 6 o'clock in the morning till 4
o'clock in the morning
sometimes and. I was sort of.
In the background or if i wasn't in
the shop was out the back organizing
and so i sort of didn't see anything
much that went on in to the activities
that went on at all. What was on the menu.
Just sandwiches and
hamburgers and pies and.
Just just a lot of junk takeaway type.
But very very popular.
Yes yes.
Well it certainly boosted business.
We didn't make a real lot of money because
we had to pay too much away in way just
to keep things flowing at an even rate
you know was very very busy to get
that stage i had during the
festival i'm sorry 27 people.
So i myself so. Money didn't.
We made money but not a lot of money.
Roll.
Each time she worked.
Why yes i guess i had harry freeman
and this was after the festival.
How if women had a few patients here
who who wouldn't take their medication
and.
A lady called murray sound and i sort
of took over the job of making sure
that these people particular people we
knew we had their medication up on our
cupboard and when they
come in of a morning.
We lined them up and
gave them their medicine
and whatever it's stay on probably on
a little bit of an even keel was of
so.
Schizophrenics mainly.
Was sad to see them at times when.
You know when they were
really off the beaten track.
And it was only people in simply because
they weren't taking their medication.
So we sort of tried to help
them out as much as possible.
I don't know whether we were thank for
it or whether they appreciate that
but we tried. Out of.
Oh i think the town. Didn't believe that.
As many people would stay here we
with well i personally thought.
That serve as a festival was open.
Everything was cleaned up everybody
would go didn't happen did it.
And. Yes and i don't think they realized
that people would want
to stay here either.
So what do you.
Changed my impression.
It's probably i don't like the
street scene at the moment
i think that it's gradually
going down hill but whether
that had anything to do with the aquarius
festival i don't know probably not.
I think that in the
last 10 years with the.
The scene in the street has
actually gone downhill.
During the festival and i don't believe
that there were any heavy drugs here.
The word drugs but i don't
think any heavy drugs
and. I really.
I'm a bit disappointed
that the town has turned out like it has
you know i think the town's probably doing
well financially as you know the
business are probably thriving now
but for all the people it but are
here and who stayed here and.
But. I don't just actually like what's
happening in town at the moment.
Do you think.
Is it a town.
I don't really know whether it's a
it's a better town i think probably.
In a lot in lots of ways it is i
guess because i mean there's more.
Employment in the area
now more business and.
And that sort of thing whether that
can be put down to the fact that.
Was the queries first of all that
made that happen. I don't know.
You know. Any. Like.
I don't know. Probably would have died.
I would say.
It was certainly on the
downhill run before.
As far as money making goes
you know the business area.
I believe it was on the downhill run.
But the general trend probably would have
brought different people here anyhow
whether the cruise festival been held
and not because all towns
all around the area.
I believe of many different
settlers of come from the city
or younger people to get away from it.
Also i think probably would have happened
to nimbleness in a certain extent
anything. Was ever any thing.
For me.
Oh yes i still is.
How do i say. Explain it. I mean.
I know that. The still a lot of
the older residents sort of.
Stand back when there's
any of them around.
They don't like accepting them.
There has been a bit of animosity.
You know times it's a flare ups of
arguments with different ones and.
But.
I don't sort of join in
that scene anymore i don't sort of
really know what is happening. But.
There used to be a lot of.
Event agonies and between the hippies
in the states especially the guys
that you to go to the pub
you know they had them.
The altercations and what
have you between them.
So a lot of them uncalled for or believe
but.
Not really you know there's been so
many little incidents that them.
You know i don't really remember anything
but you know you hear about them
and you sometimes i had seen
them arguing and what have you.
And.
No no i never ever did. I
always got on well with them.
I think i probably got more problems with
accepting. The people that are here now.
Who are coming into the area now
that i mean they're not all bad.
But i think i have more problem accepting
them now and i did back in 73.
I think. Maybe it's not.
But might be what i know about the me
or what i see and think i you know
and you know that they're on drugs and
that sort of thing i think
that's what i sort of.
How i find it harder to accept them now.
And i try and be friendly
and nice to all people.
Anyhow whether they're whether
they're hippies all come straight
or whatever supposed.
Have you got any form
and reasons for your story.
And.
Not really you know i can't.
Sort of spur the moment i can't sort
of think of anything. You mean.
During festival kyle
after first of all time.
No.
Oh dear. I don't really doubt one of
the funniest things i saw wasn't funny
but it was amazing.
There were so many people in my shop and i
was up and down behind the counter and.
And the wall verona cream walls in this
particular room where they used to always
go and sit need and. I went in
there. Halfway through the morning.
One morning and they all got pictures
drawn painted all over them.
The artist come in with
their paints and brushes
and painted pictures around the walls and
actually we left the mayor for years
and years. I don't know where
they ever got to when the lady
that bought the shop after they
had them pull down thrown away
but there were some very good pictures
that that was sort of. Set me back.
I think oh goodness me that didn't
take long for that to happen.
That was interesting
and i can't really think
of too not too much.
Lost.
I think so.
How much.
Probably didn't change that much
straight away but a guy came in
and painted all pictures on the rooms
and on the front of the shops and
that sort of thing. But
that was sometime after
wasn't straightaway. So.
How about. You know. Children.
Yes i had all my youngest
boy was one year old
during. First of all time and.
I'd two girls who lived with me
and another son who was he was
that age.
They got a lot out of the festival. And
so they would say the one year old did.
But the girls did they they
made heaps of friends and
and sort of joined in activities when
they were had time off from the shop
and they really enjoyed
actually just being
that last night you know they were both.
One more so than the other said that
they are glad they experienced it.
You know and that she
was a little bit older
and was old enough to probably appreciate
what was happening around the other one
didn't sort of. Appreciate it as much
but she she said she's glad
she experienced it too.
So what about.
They grew up and.
Yes and we didn't stop them from
associating with the new settlers
or you know they to go visit people who
had their dinners and their places.
I think probably by letter
after letting them do that.
It sort of opened their eyes as
to what can happen to people
and none of them ever ever
wanted to sort of go in
that direction they. I think
they could probably see.
You know that's all. But
that life not for me.
You know they had the opportunity to do
it if they wanted to but they didn't so.
When you told. Oh well you
know. Just just living in a.
And. Not combing your hair and.
Going shoeless and that sort of thing
that yes i think they sort of well
you know i don't want to do that.
I you know they had the
opportunity to do it.
Had they wanted to but none
of them had wanted to go on.
I'm actually glad about
that. And you know.
Another generation.
There's the children of the query and
yes there's quite a few of them.
I can't call recall. Any special one.
But there are a lot of youngsters
and there's a lot of youngsters who
have done well for themselves too
and there's a lot that haven't and
who don't want to you know that.
Age group so.
They're happy to live on the streets
call themselves street kids
but biggest majority of their parents
live here anyhow so i don't believe
that there's even call a street kid a street
kid if their parents live in the area.
I think that they've got parents
that's what they should be.
I mean how you judge.
How do i judge. Do you see the.